My white
breath rises in front of my eyes every time I exhale, and I
gently step on it until it disappears.
The thin strap that says you're warm is digging into your shoulders The
ply clouds vaguely threaten the moon, and you
can hardly see the stars,
but even so, I sometimes go to the sky to see the stars.
I
involuntarily close my eyes in
the country of night Even though everything is white, the
moonlight that reaches the road is weak It's not pure white like geisha's whitewash,
it's cloudy white like rain-soaked hair
Sudden  In the wind, I bury my face in my muffler and
continue walking for a while.
A tall snowman with arms
pulled out There is only something that looks like a mouth
Good evening I reply without stopping my feet My girl
buried something black in the snowman's face
and called out to me again
A girl with skin It's
only a faded dress but it doesn't look particularly
cold
I'm sure she's a Norse who's used to
the cold  And when I was about
to pass in front of the girl,
I noticed the deep blue eyes that shined against her white, prayer-powder hair and skin, and
reflexively stopped When the
footsteps disappeared, the road fell silent Snow  The
rain continued to fall, but in an instant, the world came to be called On
the way home from school,
I changed it to the end and answered, "I can't
help but pass by the girl and the
snowman."  Maybe because it
's been a while since the sun went down My studies at cram school have been slowing down I'm so
tired
But I
've been whispering all this time that
I'm going home soon
But I'll change my mind and say
thank you
Again, the girl who puts something black in the snowman's face When I
go next to him,
I drop my rucksack and lean on the
snowman I suddenly raise my eyes  Then I noticed
that the snowman's mouth is strangely
crooked.It still has no eyes or nose, but the snowman
looks like it's screaming.
I glanced at the
rucksack and the mouth of the snowman, then
I nodded and
started walking toward the white-stained Great North.
When I hold it tight, I
suddenly feel a gaze behind me There is only a girl behind
me, but as I slowly step on Yuki Usui,
for some
reason I feel that it's not her gaze
Crossing the road to
me  It's slowly approaching here The snow is
piled high here 15 centimeters would be ideal and
the ground is uneven I put my hand out of my pocket to balance it
A little girl who raises
her head Looking up at me to see if the cleaning is snow As if I should be talking to the snowman instead of me
Should I reply
?
The
snowman and the little girl floated to the surface and
I hid them
thinly.
Some are long and thin, some are short and thick.
Long, my
eldest daughter is still staring at the snowman No snowballs,
no eyes, no nose, but
she seems to be screaming Somewhere,
she seems to be crying out in intense pain
It's
a picture that seems to be 1 meter by feet It's a
picture that seems likely  Sibyl After a
while, it feels like a tool.I
grabbed three branches in my right hand and two branches in my left hand, and I straightened my
back and
walked towards
the girl.The snow stopped
before long.
After staring at the daruma
When I shift my layered gaze to this side,
I stand in front of her and hold out both of my hands.
When I suddenly saw the
words that came out of my mouth, my eyes
widened, just like a soldier pointing his bayonet at the enemy.
I plunged into
stagnation, and I am something
that numbs me. A saint who sticks out his white hand one after another while pulling it out in the snowman.
I'm determined to start protecting the forest of rams
Here's the
symptom I stuck the second branch into my belly, which is snow.
As
soon as I pulled it out, I leaned it against my back
and glanced at my backpack.
I
shuddered as if I was in a dream Soon, the snow around Edo
began to get darker, etc. The
last error slipped out of my hands, and
I'll try the last one.
I
looked at the place where I seemed to notice it, but also looked at the backpack
Then slowly lifted the corners of his mouth
and returned his gaze to
me again I didn't care about my power anymore I decided to run away but my legs won't move
Creation  The sprouts are isolating my feet I'm
screaming the drama that I can't take my eyes off of the horizontal lines
I'm screaming normally  I
don't know how long I
've run, but how much I've run and how fast my heart beats In the end, the
sea hasn't carved out my soul ni